look to me there are three great advice
givers for writers
well there are many great advice gamers
for writers but there are three
essential ones
and to me those are stephen king brandon
sanderson
and ray bradbury stephen king offers
great
information about the craft brandon
sanderson offers great information about
practicalities of being a writer and
then
you have ray bradbury whose advice is
probably the most
idealistic inspirational optimistic
whimsical i don't know
he was probably the first person who
sparked
that fire of oh my god i want to be a
writer this is the most amazing thing in
the universe
watching his videos on youtube was a big
deal to me a lot of writers who feel the
same way about ray bradbury
because he spoke with such passion about
writing and believed
truly that writing is a way to expel
your demons
to feel to disconnect and create
something great
so here are the essential advice that i
got from bradberry that i would like to
regurgitate to you
and remind myself of these days because
who doesn't need constant
reminder reminders about these sorts of
things there are four points
point number one possibly his most
difficult rule to follow
right every day that can be hard to do
sometimes especially when you have life
going on
things get in the way and you're busy
editing videos and
doing school and [ __ ] the advice is
sound
because even if you aren't physically
writing every day being able to tap into
that world that creative world and think
about your writing and think about your
stories is essential and
bradbury could also just be kind of
hyperbolic in his
the way he expressed himself i think
literally it's good to write every day
but also to be
constantly working towards a goal with
writing and and to me
the consistency is the most important
thing you can't really
improve and grow as a writer if you're
not able to make
any progress you're not able to get the
words down on page because
for years you're just you're just typing
out all of the stuff
that won't be good the only way to learn
is to just get through that phase which
everyone
apparently supposedly that's what they
tell me has to get through
point number two don't think bradberry
tells the story about how he would have
a sign pasted over
his typewriter that said don't think it
was a reminder for him that when he sat
down to write turn off the thinking part
of his brain and that's kind of a bit
antithetical to
what writers like to think about
themselves that they're thinking they're
designing their story and constructing
the plot look i'm not saying you know
structuring a plot is a bad thing or
antithetical the writing i'm just saying
the feeling the true feeling should
always be there bradberry's point was
when you sit down to write you are
opening up your heart this is what i
mean about bradbury being
emotional idealistic optimistic kind of
fellow he believes that
writing is about opening your heart and
soul and that is
very appealing to a lot of people not at
all times and it's not always
what i need to hear when i'm writing
sometimes i just need to hear like okay
what can i do to this chapter to get to
the next chapter what is wrong with my
structures at act one act two you know
that sort of stuff is great and all
at the end of the day you are writing to
express yourself to feel something you
want readers to feel something discover
something about yourself it's a
beautiful process
and when you sit down in front of the
keyboard and you're about to write i
did this with my own laptop because i
like to have my
camera covered up because i don't want
the cia watching me or anything
i usually just put a piece of tape there
but now i have a little sticker that
says don't think
i need that reminder unfortunately i do
my i take my tests on my laptop when i'm
like taking an important test
for class i read the don't think thing
it psychs me out a little bit but when
i'm writing
it's it's a nice little reminder point
number three
write down your loves and hates writer's
block
he said write down a list of things that
you love and the things that you hate
then you could write so many stories
about that there is always a fuel there
are so many things to write about for
whatever reason this piece of advice
comes into my head way more often than i
think especially when i'm trying to
generate story ideas just write a list
of things you hate and things you love
and bradbury example for him is when he
wrote fahrenheit 451 he hated
book burners so he wrote a book about
about book burners
when you draw from your own passions
there's always a well
to write from point number four read
what you love
or move on and i think this point
applies just as much to
writing write what you love or move on
and this is basically brad berry's whole
philosophy about writing is that you do
things with love
it doesn't mean you only write when you
have passion for it no
build discipline so that you can pull
that out when you write
draw up that emotion that raw emotion
when you write this
advice is useful when you don't exactly
know what to do with your writing or
with your
or with what you're reading writing is a
mysterious
process for me these these pieces of
advice
are useful they may not be useful for
everybody but for me
it reminds me of why i love to write
it's not about getting to the next
chapter
or cleaning up act one like that is part
of it of course the craft is part of it
but the reason
the motivation behind the writing is
just as
important if not more so i actually have
something cool right here i think i was
like in eighth grade
and this was at like my half price book
store and i saved up like
money i got it's a signed copy and it's
like one of my
absolute prized possessions i just
wanted to share that
brag a little bit show off oh my god i
almost dropped it
what does everyone think if you're a ray
bradbury fan how has his
writing advice affected you let's bring
in the the bradbury love here okay
yeah thanks thanks for watching like and
subscribe if you have not yet
bye bye